[Music]
this story is about a secret restaurant
in madrid
oh yes tapas no we are here for chinese
treats
how did we get down here again buckle up
that's a long story
[Music]
it all started when we got a tip saying
madrid had the secret chinese restaurant
the most authentic food ever but very
hard to find let's go
there was no email no proper address all
reviews pointed to a mysterious
underground location we called the one
number available
no response oh what a shame no wait we
didn't give up that easily we got a
friend in madrid to get to the bottom of
it and she got us the right directions
good thinking i got it i got it there
are no signs so follow these tips
we got to madrid and followed the very
detailed instructions take notes people
go to plaza espana truck get to the
southeast corner check find the parking
lot entrance go down the stairs double
check oh look i started the restaurant
remember there are no signs oh yeah i
forgot go down more stairs
go through the corridor walk a bit
whoa whoa wait
i think that's it
and that's how you find cafeteria yulung
zoo
better known as disaster
everyone meet you lung zoo and luffing
zoo oh mr fuji
and these two serve some of the most
genuine chinese food in spain
that looks so good
here
these delicacies are not just your
average chinese dumplings they're from
the couple's hometown xinjiang in the
surrounding province zeijang in
southeastern china it's actually where
the majority of madrid's chinese
really like it for a restaurant that was
this hard to find it seems like this
place never stops going
[Music]
today
[Music]
you gotta tell us who does your
marketing
i think
we'll take that as a maybe
[Music]
ah that was totally worth the trouble
please can we stop filming now i am
really hungry
[Music]
in 2010 this man forrest fenn hit a
chest filled with gold and rare
artifacts somewhere in the rocky
mountains
the search for this million dollar
treasure has obsessed thousands of
seekers worldwide
and the trail starts with this poem
which fenn wrote
it contains nine clues that point to the
treasure's location it's here someplace
where are we rolling
as i have gone alone in there and with
my treasures bowl
i can keep my secret where and hen of
rich is new and all
[Music]
fenn's motivation for hiding the
treasure was to give hope to those
knocked down by the recession
and to inspire them to explore the wild
i found a beautiful little romanesque
treasure chest and i started filling it
up with with gold coins and gold nuggets
and about 280 rubies
there are two salon sapphires there are
eight emeralds a bunch of diamonds but
mostly gold
i don't know what it's worth and i don't
even want to think about that you're not
going to be disappointed if you find
that treasure chest
[Applause]
i'm cynthia meacham and i am a full-time
treasure hunter
i have been
looking for friends treasure now for a
little over three and a half years
i hid the treasure chest
more than 8.25 miles north of santa fe
in the rocky mountains someplace
nobody knows but me
the poem that you have to solve forrest
always said you have to find where warm
waters halt and to me this is where our
warm waters halt
that's where i think that we need to
find the treasure chest
the thrill of this chase for fenn's
treasure has led many to leave the
safety of known trails and well-beaten
paths
the mountains are very unforgiving
it's extremely important that you know
what you're doing and you know where
you're going
you can end up in big trouble really
quickly
there's even one hiker that's been lost
looking for the treasure and he hasn't
been found yet
[Music]
to fen's knowledge the treasure remains
a hidden mystery
but the real reward should come from the
hunt
i was positive this was our warm waters
halt
and unfortunately i just
i don't think that this is going to be
the spot
[Music]
it doesn't matter what state you
treasure hunt in you're going to have
beautiful scenery like this
and it doesn't matter if you find a
treasure chest or not this is finding
the treasure right here
[Music]
so hear me all and listen good your
effort will be worth the coal
if you are brave and in the wood
i give you title to the gold
[Music]
somebody driving into town the first
time you wouldn't think there was a lot
here because
95 of it is hiding underground
people drive in and go
where is the place i don't understand
cuba pedi is from the aboriginal kippa
pity which means white man in a hole
[Music]
at the moment upstairs it is about
122 degrees fahrenheit down here we're
sitting on about 71 72 degrees no air
conditioner necessary we're right out in
the middle of nowhere it takes a day to
drive here from adelaide i'd say there's
about
a thousand underground dwellings and
at least 1500 people living underground
we've got five underground churches
we've got underground motels there's
some amazing underground homes here many
bedrooms underground workshop you name
it underground we've pretty well got it
[Music]
i bought my dugout as a
fairly small two-bedroom dugout and i've
been extending it over the years some of
this i blasted out
when i could get away with it the cops
don't like us blasting in town we don't
do it anymore back in the old days if
somebody was going to have a baby we'd
rock around there with a couple of
compressors on a weekend and some
jackhammers and a couple of cartons of
beer and by the sunday night we dug out
a room cemented the floor and wired it
up and
there's your new babies room honey
even though we're so far away
geographically from anywhere else
i don't know why but we just love the
place to bits
underneath the turkish region of
cappadocia a system of hidden tunnels
and caves went undiscovered for a
thousand years until one man decided to
renovate his home
[Music]
eighteen stories below the ground level
in the turkish region of cappadocia is
the ancient hidden city derenkuyu
the city was rediscovered in 1963 when a
man knocked down a wall in his basement
and stumbled across a hidden room
this triggered an excavation of the area
to reveal the hidden city that is a
thousand years old and over 280 feet
deep
it is thought to have been created
during the byzantine era around 1000 a.d
to protect the community from wars and
natural disasters
it is made up of a network of tunnels
connecting what would have been kitchens
stables churches wells and even schools
the cappadocia region is known for
subterranean safe havens and it's
speculated that dan and kuyu may have
connected many of them
the city likely could have hidden 20 000
people livestock and food supplies
making it the largest underground city
in cappadocia
located in central london is a public
park that remains hidden to even the
locals
the medieval style church of saint
dunstan in the east was built in around
1100 and has had a long 900 year old
history
in 1666 it was rebuilt after being
damaged in the great fire of london
then during world war ii a direct hit
during the london blitz destroyed a
majority of the structure leaving behind
only the north and south walls and
steeple
instead of rebuilding once again the
city of london decided to turn the
remains of some dunstan in the east into
the public garden which is accessible
today if you know where to look
tucked away from the main road the
garden is situated between the tower of
london and london bridge
the green ivy covered walls trees and
flowers offer an enchanting escape from
the city and serve as a reminder of
london's history